Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbandes für die deutsche Wissenschaft, mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 40. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsserie über Wissenschaft und wissenschaftliche Forschung. Und nachdem wir in der letzten Sendung schon einen Ausritt gemacht haben in die Neudefinition der Erdzeitalter und der recht einfachen Erkenntnis, dass diese Welt in zunehmendem Maße durch den Menschen gestaltet wird, wollen wir heute mal auf den Lebensraum des Menschen, den selbst gewählten Lebensraum, insbesondere die Städte, blicken. Um darüber mal mehr zu erfahren begrüße ich zunächst einmal meine Gesprächspartnerin, nämlich Claudia Hornberg, schönen guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag Herr Pritlove.
Frau Hornberg Sie sind Wissenschaftlerin und sind an der Universität in Bielefeld derzeit primär tätig. Das ist richtig oder?
Ist richtig genau.
Wie haben Sie denn so Ihren Einstieg in die wissenschaftliche Welt gewählt, bzw. warum haben Sie denn eigentlich Ihren Einstieg in die wissenschaftliche Welt gewählt? Oder haben Sie es gar nicht gewählt und es wurde Ihnen einfach zugetragen?
Nein ich habe es schon eigentlich gewählt. Im Grunde wird man ja geprägt finde ich einerseits natürlich viel durch das Elternhaus, aber auch durch den Ort, an dem man wohnt, durch die Plätze, an denen man sich als Kind und Jugendlicher bewegt hat. Ich glaube das hat eine sehr große Bedeutung, im Übrigen auch für Erwachsene. Also Plätze als Orte der Bedeutung für Entscheidung auch für Lebenssituationen. Und ich selber bin, das hört man wahrscheinlich auch, gebürtige Ruhrgebietlerin, ich komme aus Bochum. Und habe eigentlich dort mich schon relativ früh mit den Bereichen einerseits Stadt als recht belastete Zone beschäftigt. Wenn Sie das Ruhrgebiet nehmen, das hat heute ungefähr 5,1 Millionen Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner. Und ich selber bin in Bochum aufgewachsen und dort in einem der wenigen Naturschutzgebiete.
Einer relativ großen Stadt. Und das hat mir eigentlich immer die Bedeutung auch von innerstädtischen Grünräumen, die wir als Kinder und Jugendliche so ja nicht benannt haben, schon vor Augen geführt. Also alleine sozusagen der private, der geschützte Raum des Erlebens und des Spielens und auf der anderen Seite der Weg durch eine Stadt hin zu einer Schule. Und ich war auf einem Gymnasium mit einer naturwissenschaftlichen Schwerpunktsetzung und bin viel an dieses Thema biologische naturwissenschaftliche Fragestellungen sicherlich auch durch Lehrer, aber auch durch den ehrenamtlichen Naturschutz herangekommen. Und ich habe mich dann entschieden, Biologie zu studieren als jetzt naturwissenschaftliche Disziplin. Hatte damals schon überlegt, wollte ich nicht lieber Medizin machen? Und die Entscheidung ist aber klar für die Biologie gefallen.
Weil ich zur damaligen Zeit dachte, dass ich eine bessere Grundlagenausbildung in den Naturwissenschaften bekommen würde. Und ich glaube das ist im Nachhinein schon ein ganz wichtiger Positionspunkt gewesen für den weiteren Weg. Weil man von da aus dann auch in der Biologie ganz verschiedene Facetten von Wissenschaft auch wahrnehmen kann. Und das habe ich immer hoch spannend gefunden. Also diese erkenntnistheoretischen Zugänge, aber auch die unterschiedlichen methodischen Zugänge, gerade in den Naturwissenschaften. Das prägt sehr in der Herangehensweise auch.
Sie haben es ja nicht nur mit Biologie angehen lassen, sondern wenn ich es richtig sehe auch gleichzeitig Ökologie und Humanmedizin studiert? Ist das richtig?
Also gleichzeitig nicht, sondern nacheinander muss man sagen.
In der Reihenfolge?
Also ich habe Biologie studiert bis zum Diplom. Habe dann nach der Diplomarbeit gewechselt und muss sagen in einen sehr anwendungsbezogenen Bereich in der Waldschadensforschung habe ich dort gearbeitet bei meinem damaligen Chef und Mentor Robert Guderian, der zu der Zeit, als kaum jemand von Inter- und Transdisziplinarität gesprochen hat, schon sehr stark inter- und transdisziplinär gearbeitet hat und auf der anderen Seite sehr viel Freiheiten gegeben hat, wie an einer Hochschule gearbeitet wird. Und das ist etwas rückblickend muss ich einfach sagen, dass nicht nur Robert Guderian, sondern auch andere Mentoren und Mentorinnen, die ich hatte, mich dann auch in der Herangehensweise mitbestimmt haben und mir verschiedene Blickrichtungen dann auch mit auf den Weg gegeben haben.
Und in der Waldschadensforschung hat man natürlich zu der damaligen Zeit schon viel zu entsprechenden Schadgasen, also Stickoxide, Schwefeldioxide beispielsweise, aber auch Ozon auf Ökosysteme gearbeitet. Und auf der gleichen Ebene konnte man aber auch sich sehr intensiv schon auch mit menschlicher Gesundheit beschäftigen. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass ich im Übrigen auch nach vielen Gesprächen mit meinem damaligen Chef nochmal den Weg gegangen bin und in einem zusätzlichen Studium dann Medizin studiert habe in Düsseldorf. Damals eine der beiden Stellen in Deutschland, wo man den Bereich Umwelthygiene, Umweltmedizin recht prominent auch wissenschaftlich verfolgen konnte. Und dort habe ich nochmal für mich sehr wichtige Impulse toxikologischer Art bekommen im Rahmen jetzt der weiteren Ausbildung und meiner Doktorarbeit.
Die ich dann zu einer toxikologischen Themenstellung gemacht habe. Also ich habe promoviert, eine medizinische Promotion zur Wirkung von partikulären Luftschadstoffen auf menschliche Zellen. Also ein Thema, was ein Laborthema ist. Was damals jetzt in Deutschland, aber auch im europäischen Raum, noch relativ neu auf dem Weg war. Während in den US-amerikanischen Ländern schon sehr viel zum Thema Luftschadstoffe und menschliche Gesundheit bekannt war. Also die Amerikaner hatten damals ja die sogenannte 6-Städte-Studie, aber auch die 24-Städte-Studie dann auf den Weg gebracht. Eher umweltepidemiologische Herangehensweisen favorisiert und in der Zeit bei Professor Schlipgötter und Professor Seemeier habe ich mich dann mit inhalationstoxikologischen Fragestellungen in Zellkultursystemen beschäftigt, um zelltoxische, also zellgiftige, aber auch gentoxische oder auch Mutagene, also erbgutverändernde Effekte zu untersuchen von partikulären Luftschadstoffen.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal nachfragen, in welche Zeit fiel das? Insbesondere das ökologische Studium? Weil Waldschaden riecht so ein bisschen nach 80er Jahre.
Genau. Also das ist ein Thema gewesen, was natürlich damals an der Universität in Essen sehr prominent bearbeitet wurde. Zusammen mit einer Landesinstitution, die viel in diesem Feld auch unterwegs war. Damals das sogenannte Landesumweltamt. Und das ist im Übrigen mein erster Zugang gewesen, das wusste ich damals nicht, dass man das so nennt, das habe ich erst viel später begriffen, mein erster Zugang gewesne in Richtung eher transdisziplinärer Forschung. Also Fragen, die aus der Praxis kommen, die in die Wissenschaft gespiegelt werden. Und dann eben aus dem wissenschaftlichen Raum wieder in die Praxis gegeben werden. Und das ist schon von der methodischen Herangehensweise, die ich vorhin kurz angerissen hatte, für mich eine ganz wichtige Stellgröße damals gewesen. Dass man es lernen muss glaube ich als Wissenschaftler, nicht nur von der Metaebene zu schauen, sondern Fragestellungen, die vor Ort in Räumen existieren.
Also beispielsweise dem Ruhrgebiet oder eben auch in anderen Bereichen. Wir haben damals auch im Schwarzwald gearbeitet beispielsweise. Dass man Fragestellungen, die vor Ort gestellt werden, dann entsprechend auch nochmal wissenschaftlich reflektiert bearbeiten muss, um eventuell neue methodische Vorgehensweisen dann auch zu etablieren.
Das Thema hatten wir ja hier bei Forschergeist auch schon mit Herrn Schneidewind, transformative Wissenschaft. Das ist Ihnen sicherlich auch als Begriff bekannt, wie wahrscheinlich auch Herr Schneidewind selber. Das heißt im Prinzip haben Sie es ja recht breit angehen lassen. Also Biologie, Ökologie und dann letzten Endes auch noch den Menschen dorrt mit reinzubringen. Zeichnet sich ja fast schon das Thema ein wenig ab, all das sozusagen auch zusammen zu bringen. Also die Auswirkung des Menschen im Kontext der ökologischen Ist-Situation, bzw. dann eben auch konkret in seinem eigenen selbstgeschaffenen Lebensraum der Stadt. Das war ja damals in den 80er Jahren so ein richtiges Thema mit dem – wenn ich Waldschaden höre, fällt mir natürlich sofort als erstes dieser Begriff saurer Regen ein, das war ja sozusagen so das erste oder zumindest eine der ersten großen Debatten in Deutschland um Umweltschäden, Auswirkungen, die unmittelbar anthropogen sind sozusagen. Das hat Sie dann wahrscheinlich auch umgetrieben?
Also das ist sozusagen die eine Seite der Medaille, die mich interessiert hat. Das ist natürlich etwas, was in der Zeit ein zentrales Thema ist. Und wenn Sie sich heute die Stickoxiddiskussionen angucken oder überhaupt die Stickstoffdiskussion, dann ist das ein Thema, was heute immer noch, ein viel stärkeres Thema in meinen Augen, sein sollte als es derzeit ist. Wir haben derzeit hochaktuelle Belege national und international, die eben ganz klar zeigen, dass Stickstoffverbindungen in Ökosystemen problematisch sind, die auf der anderen Seite aber auch genauso zeigen, dass Stickstoffverbindungen, die inhalativ vom Menschen aufgenommen werden, schädigend wirken. Und insbesondere bei besonders empfindlichen Personengruppen. Und das ist eigentlich das, was mich immer interessiert hat. Und ich glaube, dass der ein Weg schon der ist, den Sie gerade adressiert haben. Der andere Weg, der mir nochmal an der Stelle wichtig ist, es ist für ein Biologen damals und ich würden behaupten auch heute noch, sehr schwer, mit der nur biologischen Qualifikationen beispielsweise im umweltbezogenen Gesundheitsschutz zu arbeiten.
Und das zeigt auch nochmal die Erfordernis meines Erachtens, Sie hatten vorhin von transformativer Wissenschaft gesprochen, das ist einerseits natürlich eine Frage der methodischen Herangehensweise. Das ist eine Frage der Fachdisziplin. Ich glaube aber auch, dass es eine Frage der Notwendigkeit ist, Ausbildungsstrukturen anders zu denken. Also gerade der umweltbezogene Gesundheitsschutz oder man kann ja auch sagen, der gesundheitsbezogene Umweltschutz, ist ein Bereich, wo unterschiedliche Ressorts und Fächer zusammen kommen. Und die Ausbildungskulturen in Deutschland sind derzeit meines Erachtens wenig geeignet, diesen Bereich mit Nachwuchs zu unterfüttern. Und das ist auch mit ein Grund, warum ich im Nachgang wirklich auch für mich selber denke, dass dieser Weg über die Biologie uns eine wirklich sehr solide medizinische Ausbildung mit einer fachärztlichen Beendigung dann auch sinnvoll und richtig gewesen ist.
Nur so haben Sie die Kompetenzen in den beiden verschiedenen Bereichen, die oftmals nicht viel miteinander sprechen.
Stellt sich schon fast die Frage, ob das so ein Kandidat für einen neu zugeschnittenen Studiengang wäre, der sich explizit mit diesen Wechselwirkungen auseinandersetzt und quasi diese ganzen Studienbereiche von vornherein schon miteinander kombiniert?
Das ist jetzt eine weitere Herzensangelegenheit, die Sie ansprechen, die mir selber sehr wichtig ist. Ich war ja lange Zeit Dekanin auch an der Fakultät  Gesundheitswissenschaften und bin derzeit ja auch gerade im Bereich Lehre immer viel unterwegs. Beschäftige mich auch viel mit Konzeption, mit kurikulären Zuschnitten von Studiengängen. Und auf der einen Seite sehe ich die Erfordernis, ja wir brauchen bestimmte Studiengänge, die derzeit sehr sehr schwach ausgebildet sind. Die sehr schwach besucht werden. Also wenn Sie den Bereich der Umweltmedizin beispielsweise nehmen, haben wir in Deutschland kaum mehr Ausbildungsstellen, haben kaum mehr Hygienelehrstühle, die in der Lage sind, im klassischen Sinne Umwelthygiene oder auch Umweltmedizin dann an die Studierenden der Humanmedizin zu adressieren. Wir haben ein ähnliches Problem im Übrigen auch mit den Toxikologielehrstühlen in Deutschland.
Die ebenso wie die Arbeitsmedizin, also auch ein recht kleines Fach, rückgebaut werden. Und das ist schone in Punkt, der mir auch in die bildungspolitische Landschaft zu adressieren sehr wichtig ist. Weil wir da an vielen Stellen Wissensverluste haben und wir sind gerade dabei, der Toxikologie ist es finde ich sehr gut gelungen, wieder Ausbaukapazitäten zu schaffen in Hinblick auf toxikologisches Lehrstühle, aber wen Sie den Bereich der fachärztlichen Ausbildung für Hygiene und Umweltmedizin beispielsweise nehmen, die ja von der Expertise her die geeigneten Fachärzten beispielsweise wären, sich in dem Feld zu tummeln, dann sieht das in Deutschland sehr schlecht aus. Und das treibt mich schon auch um.
Wie würden Sie so einen Studiengang nennen, wenn es den gäbe?
Naja Sie müssen heute die Studiengänge ja fast alle mit Anglizismen belegen.
Wir können ja auch kurz mal im Deutschen bleiben, nur so vom Bedeutungsraum.
Also ich finde schon der Begriff der Umweltmedizin ist schon sehr etabliert, der hat etwas, man könnte ihn auch nennen, Environmental Health Perspectives beispielsweise. Gibt es im internationalen Sprachraum auch. Ich glaube, dass man da sehr innovativ nach vorne gehen könnte, wenn man wirklich transdisziplinäre, interdisziplinäre oder auch transformative Forschung wählt. Das ist derzeit nicht das Thema. Die Forschung ist molekularbiologisch adressiert. Und ich glaube die Kunst wäre, diese wichtigen molekularbiologischen, zellbiologischen Ebenen mit aktuellen angewandten Fragestellungen zu verknüpfen. Da hat Deutschland eine ganz lange Historie gehabt und da ist recht viel finde ich weggebrochen. Das gilt es zu beleben. Anderer Punkt, den ich vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal ansprechen wollte, Sie haben sofort gesagt, da müsste man einen neuen Studiengang machen. Ich finde se manchmal nicht ganz unproblematisch die Vielfalt der Studiengänge, die wir haben.
Das ist sowohl für die Studierenden oder auch für die Lehrenden manchmal verwirrend. Das ist auch für Arbeitgeber verwirrend. Also ich glaube, da müsste man wirklich wohl überlegt einen Zuschnitt machen und dann nochmal einen Schritt nach vorne starten, ja das wäre sehr sinnvoll.
Jetzt haben Sie die Vergangenheit, die Historie Deutschlands schon angesprochen. Um uns mal diesem Thema der Sendung Stadt und Gesundheit ein wenig nähern zu können denke ich hilft es, vielleicht mal ganz weit zurückzublicken. Nun gab es ja nicht immer Städte, irgendwann ging es halt mal los und selbst wenn man sich glaube ich mit diesem Thema nicht so sehr auseinandergesetzt hat, was so jeder schnell sagen kann ist, gut gerochen und besonders gesund war es in den Städten ab einer bestimmten Dichte dann nicht mehr. Hat eine Weile gedauert, bis die Menschen die Dramatik von Seuchen, der Ausbreitung derselben etc. verstanden haben. Wann kann man denn sagen, dass dieser wissenschaftliche Blick auf die Thematik entstanden ist? Wann gab es diesen gesellschaftlichen Wandel, der eingesehen hat, durch die Verstädterung oder das Ausbilden des Bürgertums, der frühen Städte, schaffen wir uns auch hygienische medizinische Probleme, die wir so vielleicht vorher nicht gehabt haben?
Also ich verweis ja sehr gerne in diesem Zusammenhang auf medizinhistorisch bedeutsame Personen. Also das ist sicherlich Robert Koch, das ist Johann Peter Frank, das ist Pettenkofer, das sind aber auch Menschen wie Pasteur beispielsweise. Alles Menschen, die sich sowohl auf der einen Seite mit klassischen Krankheitserregern beschäftigt haben, die auf der anderen Seite aber immer auch den Bevölkerungsbezug und das finde ich so interessant, den Bevölkerungsbezug im Raum sich angeschaut haben. Und an der Stelle für mich eine zentrale Orientierung ist schon Robert Koch, weil er im Grunde auch so gearbeitet hat, indem er pathogene Schadfaktoren, also das Tuberkelbakterium mikroskopisch nachgewiesen hat. Sich auf der anderen Seite auch mit der Frage beschäftigt hat, die mich heute persönlich immer weiter auch noch trägt und umtreibt, was ist eigentlich und was erhält die Gesundheit von Menschen.
Auch wenn viele krankmachende Faktoren zusammenkommen. Also Robert Koch war ja jemand, der auch sehr viel in den Städten unterwegs war. Der ganz klar den Zusammenhang mit sozialer Lage beispielsweise mit Bildung, mit Zugang zu sauberem Trinkwasser beispielsweise hergestellt hat. Und diese Sichtweise liegt mehr sehr, weil ich glaube, dass sie eben neben der rein naturwissenschaftlichen Perspektive auch die soziale Perspektive und auch die Gerechtigkeitsperspektive mit in den Blick nimmt. Und an der Stelle vielleicht ein Verweis, ich bin im Sommersemester mit Studierenden sehr gerne auch auf Exkursionen unterwegs. Manche Hochschulkollegen sagen auch, ach macht ihr wieder einen Ausflug? Ich sehe, das ist ein ganz wichtiges didaktisches Element eine Exkursion. Und ich besuche mit den Studierenden sehr sehr gerne den Innenhof beispielsweise des Hamburger Rathauses.
Weil wir dort eine Bronzefigur haben, eine weibliche Bronzefigur als Allegorie für Gesundheit, die auf einen Drachen tritt. Dieser Drache ist symbolisch für die Choleraepidemie von 1892 dort abgebildet worden vom Bildhauer Joseph von Kramer. Ich glaube das war 1895 oder 1896. Und ich besuche diesen Innenhof des Hamburger Rathauses mit den Studierenden deshalb, einerseits weil er heute im Grunde in seinem Sockel immer noch die Einlässe des Belüftungssystems des Rathauses hat. Also das ist eine klassisch umwelthygienische Fragestellung. Aber was ich historisch viel interessanter finde ist, dass ursprünglich auf diesem Platz eine Figur des Handelsgottes Merkur geplant war. Und man hat sich nach der Cholera-Epidemie mit tausenden von Toten für die Göttin der Reinheit entschieden.
Und dieses Spannungsfeld, also zwischen Gesundheit und Krankheit auf der einen Seite, aber auch ökonomischen Frakturen, das ist ja das, was uns heute derzeit in Städten mehr denn je eigentlich umtreibt. Und wir sind ja derzeit, wenn wir den internationalen Raum betrachten, in einer der größten Verdichtungsphasen überhaupt. Also das Stichwort Megacitys, wenn wir international gucken, das treibt ja weltweit sehr sehr viele nicht nur Wissenschaftler, sondern auch Nichtregierungsorganisationen um die Weltgesundheitsorganisation, weil wir natürlich dort einerseits Endpunkte von Migrationsprozessen haben, weil wir auf der Seite aber dann eben auch in diesen Endpunkten von Migrationsprozessen Menschen haben, die auf Arbeit hoffen, die auf soziale Bezüge hoffen, die aus infektionsepidemiologischer Sicht gesehen, aber dann unter Umständen auch wieder Überträger von Krankheiten sein können.
Die Ressourcen in Anspruch nehmen. Also Boden, Wasser, Luft beispielsweise. Also die Stadt als solches ist ja nicht nur in Deutschland ein Thema, sondern sie ist international im Zuge der Megacity Diskussion natürlich auch ganz zentral. Und ich glaube wir tun gut daran, auch im wissenschaftlichen Bereich uns dieser internationalen Frage viel viel stärker zu widmen. Klammer auf, wenn Sie sich den Ballungsraum Ruhrgebiet anschauen oder auch die Rheinschiene mit dazu nehmen, dann haben wir dort natürlich auch Millionen von Menschen und wo wir uns schon auch überlegen müssen und er aktuellen Situation wie kriegen wir beispielsweise den Wohnungsbau, den Städtebau, die Stadt- und Raumplanung als die Institution, als die Fachbereiche, die ja letztendlich die Welten von Morgen schaffen, frühzeitig mit ins Boot.
Also meine These ist Stadt- und Raumplaner und Architekten schaffen die Lebensverhältnisse für Morgen und die bestimmen letztendlich auch die sogenannten Gesundheitsdeterminanten mit.
Bevor wir vielleicht in diesen, auch so ein bisschen ein Blick in die Zukunft oder sagen wir zumindest in die nahe Gegenwart, wie man jetzt sozusagen dem Ganzen Herr wird. Ich wollte nochmal so ein bisschen versuchen herauszuarbeiten, welchen Dingen man jetzt eigentlich Herr werden muss bzw. auch, welchen Dingen denn zunächst einmal man Herr wurde. Sie haben jetzt Robert Koch genannt, der im Wesentlichen für die Bekämpfung der Tuberkulose bekannt ist, aber darüber hinaus eine Wirkung in der Wissenschaft hatte, mir ist jetzt nicht 100% klar, was für eine Zeitenwende er in seiner Disziplin konkret eingeleitet hat. Vielleicht können Sie dazu nochmal was sagen. Dann haben Sie auch noch andere Vertreter genannt, was haben die dazu beigetragen und was hat das sozusagen für Entwicklungen eingeleitet?
Also ich glaube, was für alle vorgenannten Vertreter typisch war ist, dass sie eine Herangehensweise hatten, die einerseits ein ganz klassisch naturwissenschaftliches Setting gewählt haben, um Erkenntnisse neu zu erarbeiten. Das heißt das war eine Zeit, in der insbesondere natürlich auch die Laboratorien viel genutzt wurden und was all den vorgenannten Menschen glaube ich zu eigen war, dass sie es geschafft haben, doch noch aus ihren Laboratorien wieder herauszugehen und den Bezug zur Bevölkerung zu sehen. Also das was wir heute bevölkerungsmedizinischen Bezug nennen. Das haben die geschafft. Und das unterscheidet glaube ich unsere aktuelle Situation. Weil wir haben in der aktuellen Situation meines Erachtens zu wenig Wissenschaftler, die genau diese beiden Komponenten miteinander spielen können.
Die auf der einen Seite eher anwendungsbezogen arbeiten und trotzdem noch grundlagenorientiert sind. Ich glaube die Wissenschaft derzeit macht gerade wieder eine Kehrbewegung, indem man so etwas wie transdisziplinäre Zugänge oder auch transformative Wissenschaft in den Blick nimmt. Aber wir haben lange lange Jahre fokussiert auf die harte labororientierte zellbiologische molekularbiologische Grundlagenwissenschaft, ohne den Raumbezug daneben zu stellen. Und ich glaube, das ist das was in dieser Zeit sehr gut und sehr gekonnt gelebt wurde. Und ich bin froh, dass wir derzeit im Bereich jetzt der Transformatorenforschung oder auch transformativen Perspektive wieder an dem Schritt angelangt sind, dass man sagt, Wissenschaft kann eigentlich nicht mehr länger über Jahre zunächst erst mal Ergebnisse erarbeiten und gibt sich vielleicht gar nicht mehr an die Allgemeinheit zurück.
Sondern ich glaube Wissenschaft wird derzeit sehr häufig nachgefragt, auch mit dem berechtigen Anspruch was macht ihr da und erklärt bitte, was ihr macht. Und was bringen eure Ergebnisse, was bringen eure Daten, um gesellschaftliche Prozesse auch vielleicht neu zu steuern. Ich glaube das ist ja auch eine Verantwortlichkeit von Wissenschaftlern zu sagen, was sie warum macht, aber auch zu sagen, was hat ihre  Arbeit eigentlich mit gesellschaftlichen Prozessen zu tun.
Ich würde schon gerne nochmal diesen Blick nach hinten wagen, um ein bisschen bessern zu verstehen, welche Änderung das auch hervorgebracht hat. Also Robert Koch hat ungefähr vor 140 Jahren so seine großen Durchbrüche ins Feld geführt. Das heißt man könnte jetzt sagen, wir blicken vielleicht so grob auf 150 Jahre zurück, wo einerseits klar ist, die Städte sind ein starkes dominantes Ding in unserer Gesellschaft, wo wir uns neue Probleme schaffen durch die Art und Weise des Zusammenlebens, durch die Nähe der Leute und vielleicht eben dann auch durch den Mangel der Hygiene. Louis Pasteur hatten Sie noch genannt, der mit der Pasteurisierung, der uns sozusagen die Haltbarkeit der Milch besorgt hat. Und Herr Johann Peter Frank.
Das ist doch derjenige, der sich für öffentliche Hygiene eingesetzt hat, sehe ich das richtig?
Ja.
Also damit ging es irgendwie los. Und was hatte das für eine Wirkung in der Wissenschaft. Ich meine war das dann sozusagen sofort klar, so ah ja jetzt müssen wir uns hier drauf fokussieren und dann waren die Probleme schon weitgehend verstanden? Oder waren das eher nur so Einzelkämpfer und keiner hat irgendetwas daraufhin folgen lassen? Oder hat das schon Wirkung gezeigt?
Also es hat zu der Zeit natürlich Wirkung gezeigt. Weil das waren erst mal Schritte nach vorne, um im Grunde die Todesraten zu reduzieren, die bis dahin im Rahmen von Infektionskrankheiten dann auch stattgefunden haben. Also das war ja eigentlich die Intervention, die dann alle die von Ihnen gerade benannten abgeleitet haben. Also das was wir früher …
Sowohl in der Produktion, als auch in der Bekämpfung.
Genau, wir haben früher eine sehr sehr hohe Sterblichkeit auch, insbesondere Kinder- und Säuglingssterblichkeit, Jugendsterblichkeit gehabt aufgrund von Infektionskrankheiten und das ist eigentlich der entscheidende Schritt, der diesen genannten Personen zuzuordnen ist. Und auf der anderen Seite haben sie aber auch schon schnell gesehen, dass städtische Lebensumwelt, und deshalb würde ich das gerne noch einmal in eine etwas andere Richtung justieren, in vielerlei Hinsicht aber auch Gesundheit und Wohlbefinden und Lebensqualität positiv beeinflusst. Also das möchte ich ausdrücklich nochmal hervorheben, dass Städte natürlich nicht nur krank machen. Sondern dass Städte eine ganze Reihe von gesundheitsförderlichen Eigenschaften haben. Also wenn Sie die Kommunikationsstruktur nehmen, die Interaktionsstrukturen, dann haben wir da natürlich auch sehr gute Möglichkeiten, positive Aspekte des städtischen Zusammenlebens genauer anzugucken.
Und das haben die auch schon sehr wohl getan. Also auch damals gab es ja auch, wenn ich jetzt den Bereich der Medizin verlasse, wenn Sie den Bereich der Stadt- und Raumplanung nehmen, auch damals gab es schon Menschen, die sich natürlich mit der Notwendigkeit von urbanen Grün- und Blauräumen, also innerstädtischen Gewässern beschäftigt haben. Also das ist mir wirklich nochmal wichtig festzuhalten. Man darf Stadt nicht begreifen als ein großer Organismus, der nur krank macht. Sondern wir haben in Städten zentrale Bereiche, die für viele Menschen lebenswichtig sind. Und wir haben auch in verschiedenen Städten, wir nennen das eine sogenannte sozialräumliche Gliederung, wo Sie eben Stadtgebiete haben, die stärker belastet sind. Und Sie haben aber andere Stadtgebiete, die sind weniger belastet, und Sie haben sehr viel Grünräume. Also beispielsweise die Hellwegreihe, also das Ruhrgebiet. Wenn Sie von Duisburg gehen, über Mülheim, Essen, Bochum, Dortmund, dann sind das Städte, die haben so einen sozialräumliche Gliederung.
Auch historisch im Übrigen wieder gewachsen durch den Steinkohlebergbau. Wo Sie eigentlich die nördlichen Bereiche hatten, die eine stärkere Belastung hatten. Wo Sie vielfach Bevölkerungsgruppen hatten, die geringeres Einkommen hatten. Und Sie hatten in den südlichen Bereichen eine ganz andere Lebenssituation für die Menschen in den Städten, niedrige Belastungsquoten und trotzdem dann entsprechende Grünräume. Also diese sogenannte sozialräumliche Gliederung das ist ja etwas, was sich eigentlich auch immer durch die Diskussion sowohl in der umwelthygienischen, umweltmedizinischen Diskussion sehen, aber auch in der städtebaulichen Diskussion. Und das finde ich das Interessante, das übereinander zu legen. Und das hat für mich auch heute einen wichtigen Themenstrang in sich, dass man wirklich nochmal klar sagen muss, auch wenn der Druck der Zeit noch so groß ist, beispielsweise Wohnung zu bauen.
Und natürlich Städte den Erfordernissen entsprechend zu bauen, muss man sich klar machen, dass urbane Grünräume und Gewässer beispielsweise als klimaökologische Ausgleichsräume dienen. Das ist in Zeiten, beispielsweise wo das Thema Klimawandel bzw. Temperaturerhöhung gerade in den Sommermonaten ein ganz wichtiges Thema ist und wir müssen uns darüber wieder Gedanken machen. Und da mache ich gerne den Blick zurück und gucke mir an, was haben Menschen eigentlich früher in Forschung, in Wissenschaft, aber auch in kommunaler Anwendungspraxis getan, um eben genau solche klimaökologischen Ausgleichsräume oder aber auch Bewegungs- oder Regenerationsräume zu schaffen. Und das sind ja vielfach einzelne Personen. Also ich lebe jetzt seit über einem Jahrzehnt in Ostwestfalen in Bielefeld.
Und Bielefeld hat einen Gartenbaudirektor gehabt, der für sich als Idee gehabt hat, jeder Bielefelder soll innerhalb von spätestens 15 Minuten einen innerstädtischen Grünraum erreichen. Und das sind genauso Menschen, die mit einer solchen Idee, die dann praktisch umgesetzt wird, dazu andere Menschen bewegen, sich vielleicht gesundheitsförderlicher zu bewegen. Und das ist das, was mich immer auch interessiert. Dass in der praktischen Umsetzung gerade von transdisziplinärer Arbeit sie sehr viel als Wissenschaftlerin und als Wissenschaftler mit Kommunen zu tun haben. Mit Menschen, die vor Ort gewohnt sind und auch damit antreten, etwas für die Bevölkerung zu tun.
Jetzt haben Sie ja an der Universität Bielefeld eine Zeit lang eine Forschergruppe geleitet, die sich da speziell mit auseinandergesetzt hat, das klang am Rande schon an. Wenn ich das richtig sehe unterstützt von der Fritz und Hildegard Berg Stiftung. Was war die Aufgabe dieser Forschergruppe? Und wie haben Sie dann dieses Thema sich erarbeitet?
Also wir waren damals sehr froh, dass wir die erste Forschergruppe, Juniorforschergruppe, so hieß sie damals, ich nenne sie lieber Forschergruppe, wir hatten damals das Glück, die erste Juniorforschergruppe zu bekommen, im Förderschwerpunkt, so heißt er immer noch, Stadt der Zukunft – gesunde und nachhaltige Metropolen. Und Sie hatten gerade richtig gesagt, das ist ein Förderschwerpunkt der Fritz und Hildegard Berg Stiftung, was eben im Rahmen des deutschen Stifterverbandes dann auch finanziert wird. Wir haben inzwischen vier solcher Forschergruppen, also wir waren die erste. Es gab eine zweite dann in Dortmund. Es gibt eine Stuttgart, es gibt eine in Berlin, die jetzt ganz frisch angefangen hat.
Und die Idee dieses Förderprogramms ist, dass die beiden Leitkonzepte nachhaltige Gesundheitsförderung, also Sie sehen da steckt der Begriff der Nachhaltigkeit drin und die nachhaltige Entwicklung am Beispiel urbaner Räume miteinander verknüpft werden soll. Also das gilt für alle Juniorforschergruppen. Und diese Juniorforschergruppen sind alle inter- und transdisziplinär zugeschnitten. Die haben unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte. Also unser Schwerpunkt hatte ganz klar die Ansage, wir sollten und wollten uns, ich muss es andersrum sagen, wir wollten und durften uns dann hinterher mit der gesundheitlichen Bedeutung von urbanen Grünräumen, also von Stadtgrün, beschäftigen. Und wollten gleichzeitig gucken, welche Rolle spielen eigentlich innerstädtische Gewässer, also Stadtblau.
Im Zusammenhang mit Gesundheit. Und das ist ein Punkt, den wir damals beantragt hatten. Also Juniorgruppenforscherleiter war Dr. Thomas Klaassen, ich war die verantwortliche Hochschullehrerin. Uns beiden war dieses Thema der urbanen Gewässer deshalb so wichtig, weil auch da historisch sehr gut zu zeigen ist, dass innerstädtische Gewässer völlig rückgebaut wurden. Und wir wollten natürlich wissen, wie ist da eigentlich der Ist-Stand, und was kann man tun, um gerade in Zeiten der Überhitzung, der Überwärmung in Städten, wenn Sie an den August 2003 denken beispielsweise, wie kann man sich da diesen innerstädtischen Gewässern wieder nähern und wie kann deren Bedeutung eigentlich für die Menschen dann quantifizieren oder vielleicht auch eben im Rahmen von Befragung qualitativ erheben.
Also wir haben auch viel uns im Bereich Ästhetik umgetrieben. Wir waren eine gemischte Forschergruppe. Das heißt es waren einerseits klassische Gesundheitswissenschaftler dabei, soweit man sagen kann, dass Gesundheitswissenschaftler schon klassisch sind, das ist ja noch ein relativ junges Fach Public Health in Deutschland. Es waren aber auch beispielsweise Landschaftsarchitekten dabei, die sich darum gekümmert haben. Es waren Geografen beteiligt und diese interdisziplinäre Sichtweise fanden wir schon recht spannend. Und Sie hatten ja vorhin gefragt, was war letzten Endes zugrundeliegende Frage? Wir sind angetreten mit fünf Stipendiaten im Rahmen dieses inter- und transdisziplinär ausgerichteten Vorhabens, die Frage zu klären, welche Beiträge zur Gesundheitsförderung eben durch diese Grünräume und Gewässer geleistet werden können auf der einen Seite.
Aber auch mit den kommunalen Vertreter der Städte Gelsenkirchen und Bielefeld gemeinsam zu überlegen, wie sind denn eigentlich urbane Grünräume und Gewässer zu schützen und wie sind sie unter Umständen zu optimieren. Weil wir eben sagen, das ist etwas, was vielfach nicht genügend berücksichtigt wird. Und unsere Idee war, die Bereiche, die normalerweise in Umweltdezernaten und Gesundheitsdezernaten oder auch Sozialdezernaten vielleicht zugeordnet werden, ein bisschen in der Erkenntnis zu stärken, um einfach auch zu schauen, was kann man eigentlich der reinen baulichen Fragestellung von Städten entgegensetzen.
Gehen wir doch da mal rein. Ich finde das eigentlich ganz spannend. Sie fragten ja, welche Wirkung können durch Gewässer überhaupt erzielt werden. Ich denke man macht sich immer relativ wenig klar, welche Bedeutung so ein Fluss hat, außer dass man drin baden kann und dass er irgendwie im Idealfall hübsch aussieht und nicht stinkt. Welche Rolle spielt Wasser in der Gesamtökologie einer Stadt und widmen wir dem bereits genug Aufmerksamkeit?
Also die Frage ist ja, wie Sie Wasser jetzt betrachten. Wenn Sie aus anthropozäntischer Sicht drauf schauen, dann heißt es ja durch die Brille jetzt des Menschen, dass ich erst mal feststellen muss, dass wir sehr wenig innerstädtische Gewässer haben. Und ich würde nicht unbedingt bei Flüssen anfangen, sondern ich würde anfangen schon auch bei kleinere Gewässern, die ja in früheren Zeiten, also wir sprachen vorhin ja schonmal über die 80/90er Jahre im Rahmen von Biotopkartierung beispielsweise, auch erhoben wurden. Und wo sie sehr klar zeigen konnten, dass eben gerade auch diese kleinräumigen Gewässerstrukturen eine sehr sehr wichtige Bedeutung haben für die Biodiversität in Städten.
Also kleine Seen, kleine Bäche.
Kleine Bäche insbesondere, insbesondere Fließgewässer. Diese kleineren Fließgewässer sind vielfach ja dann zurückgebaut worden und sind im Rahmen jetzt der Vorfluterdiskussion, Sie haben ja gerade auch schon den Aspekt angesprochen, es gibt ja auch sogenannten wassergetragene Keime, die durchaus eben auch menschliche Gesundheit beeinträchtigen können, diese kleineren Fließgewässer sind vielfach zurückgebaut worden und das hat eigentlich für mich mindestens zwei wesentliche Folgen. Der eine Punkt ist der, dass sich die innerstädtische kleinräumige Klimaregulation verändert hat, weil wir eben seit langem wissen aus ökologischen Untersuchungen, dass Stadtgewässer kühlende Effekte gerade eben in den Sommermonaten haben.
Auf der anderen Seite, ganz wichtig aus Sicht der Landschaftsarchitekten, ist ein wesentlicher ästhetischer Fokus verloren gegangen. Viele Menschen beschrieben gerade Gewässer in den Städten als hochattraktiv, alleine jetzt im Sinne von Regenerationsmöglichkeit, aber auch beispielsweise als Animationsraum für Bewegung. Also man läuft entlang von Flüssen. Wenn Sie sich den Rhein angucken beispielsweise, wenn Sie sich die Ruhr als größere Flüsse angucken. Innerstädtische Gewässer sind beispielsweise auch Begegnungsräume, das muss man ganz klar sagen, wo sich unterschiedliche Kulturen, unterschiedliche Bevölkerungsgruppen bewegen. Es sind auch Erlebnisräume. Also die haben eine ganz wichtige soziale Funktion. Wenn ich mir die Bevölkerung ansehe neben der reinen biodiversitäts- oder auch klimaökologischen Funktion.
Das kann man ja ganz gut miteinander in Beziehung setzen. Und man kann sich glaube ich städtebaulich viel überlegen, wie man innerstädtische Blauräume, so nennen wir sie, dann aufwertet und auch wieder entsprechend der Bevölkerung, aber auch der Natur zurückgibt. Und wir haben ja im Ruhrgebiet beispielsweise ein ganz großes Projekt, was schon lange unterwegs ist, was viel Kraft, viel Ideen, aber auch viele Initiativen gebündelt hat, der Emscher Umbau, die Emscher Renaturierung. Also dieses Thema, der ökologischen Transformation von Siedlungsräumen ist ja ein ganz zentrales Thema, was im Moment gerade vor dem Hintergrund der Vielschichtigkeit von urbanen Grünräumen und urbanen Gewässern auch schon in die Umsetzungsphasen gegangen ist. Und da bin ich ganz froh, dass wir das im Rahmen jetzt dieses Förderschwerpunktes über einen Zeitraum von drei Jahren aus ganz unterschiedlichen Perspektiven miteinander bearbeiten konnten.
Die Emscher ist für den Ruhrgebietler im Grunde der große Entsorgungswasserträger gewesen oder ist es immer noch. Das heißt das gesamte Abwasser läuft über die Emscher. Und die Idee derzeit ist, und das ist ja auch schon fast historisch zu nennen, diese Planung jetzt umzusetzen im Rahmen einer ökologischen Renaturierung dann entsprechende Umsetzungsmöglichkeiten und Veränderungsmöglichkeiten hinzubekommen. Also Stichwort Transformation, Sie hatten es vorhin angesprochen oder ökologische Transformation, es hat in der Zeit vor zig Jahren Artikel gegeben von Herrn Ganser, beispielsweise damit die Emscher wieder plätschert, wo er konzeptionell dargelegt hat finde ich in einem sehr sehr schönen Artikel, warum man letztendlich einen solchen begradigten Flusslauf wieder aus seiner Begradigung herauslösen muss.
Um da entsprechend die vielschichtigen Möglichkeiten, die ein Fließgewässer bietet, dann auch wieder nutzbar zu machen.
Aber es ist nicht nur ein Entsorgungskanal, sondern war auch vor allem zum Transportkanal umgebaut worden für den Bedarf des Kohleabbaus.
Genau.
Was machen denn die meisten Städte falsch, sagen wir es mal so. Also was sind denn sozusagen die niedrighängenden Früchte im Umgang mit Flüssen? Was könnte denn eine Stadt wie Berlin, Hamburg hat ja recht viel Wasser, wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht ganz oben auf der Liste von Städten, die dringend mal was ändern müssten, was macht man denn so falsch? Also die Begradigung hatten Sie schon angesprochen, dass die Flüsse zu schnell fließen und auch zu wenig Überlaufräume haben. Das ist ja auch ein Thema bei Überflutungen etc. Aber so rein für die Gesundheit, für die Ökologie der Stadt, was kann man tun mit den Blauräumen?
Also ich würde jetzt erst mal gar nicht fragen, was machen die Städte alle falsch, sondern ich würde glaube ich erst mal gucken, was machen Städte richtig. Weil wir gehen schon immer auch vom sogenannten Ressourcenansatz aus und wir gucken eigentlich, wer ist wie unterwegs und wer ist an welchen Stellen auch so unterwegs, dass man das auf andere Kommunen übertragen kann. Und in Berlin finde ich gibt es eine Reihe an Akteuren, beispielsweise die sich schon sehr klar gemacht haben, welchen Wert diese innerstädtischen Gewässer haben. Ich würde gerne nochmal auf diesen Punkt Emscher zurückkommen, weil der mir schon sehr am Herzen liegt, weil er deutlich macht, wie lange so ein Prozess auch dauert. Man muss einfach sagen, das sind ja Kanalisierungen über sehr lange Bereiche, wenn Sie die Emscher angucken. Es sind glaube ich insgesamt 360 Kilometer, die da im Grunde zunächst erst mal wiederbelebt werden mussten.
Und wo lange Perspektiven auch zunächst erst mal ein Konzept entwicklen mussten. Und ich glaube, daran fehlt es manchmal, dass wir schon auch vor Ort sehr viele Akteure haben, die sehr engagiert sind. Dass wir aber so eine langfristige Perspektive, was eben auch Raumentwicklung angeht, viel zu wenig spielen und aufrecht erhalten. Also das wäre mir wichtig, dass man jenseits von Wahlperioden eben auch nochmal guckt, wie kann ich eigentlich die Bereiche Stadtökologie, Stadtgesundheit und Stadtökonomie miteinander in Beziehung setzen. Also das heißt, es läuft für mich schon auch auf den kommunalen Ebenen darauf hinaus, dass wir eigentlich eher eine integrierende Umwelt-, Sozial- und Gesundheitspolitik brauchen.
Und konkret vor Ort heißt das natürlich, ich brauche in der Kommune ein starkes Umweltamt, was in der Lage ist, zunächst erst mal was zu Umweltqualitäten zu sagen und Ziele zu entwickeln, die eine Kommune dann in bestimmten Zeiträumen umsetzen will. Also das ist etwas, was man jeder Kommune und da sind viele Kommunen, deshalb habe ich das auch gerade auch nochmal betont, da sind glaube ich viele Kommunen inzwischen sehr sehr gut unterwegs, wirklich zu gucken, was haben sie und wo wollen sie damit hin? Das hängt an einzelnen Akteuren.
Aber was sind denn so Beispiele für eine gute Maßnahme?
Beispiele sind Renaturierungsprojekte, die vor Ort gemacht werden. Beispiele sind auch Masterlläne beispielsweise, die zusammen mit Landesregierungen auf den Weg gebracht werden. Also Nordrhein-Westfalen hat in der letzten Koalitionsvereinbarung Masterplan Umwelt und Gesundheit stehen gehabt. Wo sehr dezidiert, auch jetzt im Rahmen von konkreten Aktionen mit den Kommunen vor Ort, geguckt wird, was sind innerstädtische Bereiche, beispielsweise die besonders belastet sind. Ich komme auf unsere Modellstadt Gelsenkirchen beispielsweise zurück, die vorbildlich eine integrierte Umweltberichterstattung hat und die sehr klar sagen können, an welchen Stellen haben wir beispielsweise wenig Grünräume, an welchen Stellen haben wir wenig innerstädtische Gewässer und was müssen wir tun, um dort neue Grünräume oder auch vielleicht eben Gewässer anzulegen? Und was heißt das aber auch mit Blick auf unter Umständen gesundheitliche Outcomes, also gesundheitliche Wirkungen.
Ja aber das ist ja jetzt nicht nur eine Frage von Berichterstattung, und es geht auch nicht immer darum, nur neues anzulegen, sondern vielleicht muss man auch mit dem Wasser einfach umgehen? Also was sind denn so erfolgreiche Maßnahmen, die Städte jetzt ganz konkret in Angriff genommen haben, um einfach der Stadt mehr Gesundheit zu bringen.
Indem sie beispielsweise Fließgewässer wieder offenlegen. Indem sie renaturieren, wie ich das vorhin gesagt habe. Indem sie Bachläufe wieder zum mäandrieren bringen. Indem sie beispielsweise Abwasserstrecken trennen von unbelasteten Gewässerbereichen. Und die unbelasteten Gewässerbereiche freilegen und dann eben innerstädtisch für den Menschen sichtbar und erfahrbar machen. Und im Grunde die Abwasserfracht getrennt, zusammen natürlich ist der Siedlungswasserwirtschaft beispielsweise unter die Erde packen. Und so Räume wieder aufwerten. Das finde ich ist sehr konkret ein Beispiel, wie man eben diesen Aspekt Klimaschutz oder Klimaanpassung in Kommunen sehr viel stärker spielen kann. Das machen viele Kommunen im Übrigen auch. Also wir haben im Rahmen eines Forschungsprojektes, was wir fürs Bundesumweltministerium gemacht haben, Klimaanpassungsprozesse in unterschiedlichsten Kommunen bundesweit angeguckt.
Und da muss man ganz klar sagen, es gibt eigentlich nicht die Lösung, die für alle Kommunen passt. Sondern Ziel muss es sein, auf Basis vorhandener Daten, Sie hatten ja gerade richtig gesagt, es lohnt ja nicht nur, eine Berichterstattung zu machen, ich bin Anhängerin von einer integrierten Berichterstattung, wo sie eben auch die Umweltdaten so gut haben müssen, dass sie greifbar sind. Und wenn Sie die haben, dann können Sie auf Basis dieser Berichterstattung und auf Basis Ihrer beispielsweise demographischen oder soziodemografischen Daten einer Stadt können Sie sehr kleinräumig sagen, was Sie vor Ort machen. Und das heißt es kann beispielsweise sein, Sie werten Grünräume auf qualitativ, es kann aber auch sein, dass Sie sagen, wir planen einen neuen Bachlauf. Das ist aber individuell vor Ort zu entwickeln. Da gibt es jetzt nicht die große Planung, die man sozusagen über alle Kommunen führen kann.
Das ist klar, da muss man sich an Beispielen entlang hangeln. Da würde mich auch gleich nochmal den entsprechenden … - Sie sagten ja auch, eine Fragestellung ist, wie schützt und optimiert man urbane Grünräume? Also dass man viele davon haben sollte, ich denke das ist jetzt eine Binsenweisheit. Das hätte jeder gern, viel Platz, viel Park, viel Grün.
Das weiß ich gar nicht so, ob das jeder gerne hätte. Wir haben 30 ha Ziel in Deutschland, da sind wir relativ weit von entfernt, das zu erreichen.
Was heißt das Ziel?
Wir wollen ja versuchen, den Flächenverbrauch zu reduzieren. Und die konkurrente Lage beispielsweise, die ist schon für mich in Deutschland gegeben. Wir wollen auf der einen Seite, ganz klar wenn es um Etablierung von Nachhaltigkeitszielen geht, sondern wir wollen beispielsweise mehr eine Reduktion des Flächenverbrauchs oder wir wollen mehr Schutz der Biodiversität. De facto muss man aber schon sagen, dass die Ausweisung von Flächen, die zur Bebauung dann freigegeben sind, schon auch enorm sind. Also ich sehe da schon jenseits der kommunalen Situation natürlich auch die Bundesländer und auch die Bundesebene in der Pflicht, dieses Thema Reduktion des Flächenverbrauchs in Angriff zu nehmen. Und was mir noch mal wichtig ist, das haben wir bislang noch nicht angesprochen, das fällt mir jetzt ein.
Dass Sie die Städte natürlich insofern sehr differenziert betrachten müssen, als dass es Städte gibt, die boomen. Also wenn Sie Berlin nehmen Zuwachs, wenn Sie Köln nehmen beispielsweise das ist eine ganz andere Situation als Regionen, wie beispielsweise das Ruhrgebiet, wo Flächen frei werden. Also wo Sie ganz anders auch mit freiwerdenden Flächen vielleicht auch im rahmen von Planungsprozessen umgehen können. Da fällt es ja viel viel einfacher unter Umständen, wenn ich ein gutes kommunales Konzept habe, Flächen auszuweisen, die dann vielleicht einen höheren Wert für Biodiversität oder für urbane Wildnis beispielsweise haben. Also da möchte ich wirklich nochmal drauf hinweisen, dass man sehr differenziert mit den Stadt- und Raumplanern da auch nochmal angucken muss, wie ist der Druck auf eine Stadt.
Und eine Stadt, die boomt, wo ein großer Zuzug pro Jahr ist, die hat natürlich eine ganz andere Problemstellung und muss sich ganz anders aufstellen als eine Stadt, die nicht so attraktiv ist.
Und inwiefern muss man die Grünräume schützen. Also meinen Sie jetzt nur mit nicht entfernen oder braucht sozusagen ein Grünraum auch nochmal im Kontext der Stadt einen besonderen Schutz, den es jetzt erst mal so von sich aus heraus nicht selber aufbauen kann? Worum geht es da?
Also ich glaube es geht um beides. Ich erinnere mich, als ich nach Bielefeld kam, es gibt in Bielefeld eine sehr interessante Institution, das ist Bielfeld 2000plus, eine Einrichtung, die sich zusammensetzt aus Kommunalvertretern und universitären Vertretern und im Rahmen dieser Konstruktion Bielefeld 2000plus wurde eine Untersuchung gemacht zur Bedeutung von Stadtgrün für die Bielefelder Bevölkerung. Und der Hintergrund dieser Untersuchung war, dass man Bielefeld als weichen Standortfaktor betrachten wollte. Also ich nehme mal ein eigenes Beispiel, Sie haben einen Ruf nach München und Sie haben einen Ruf an die Universität Bielefeld, warum sollten Sie sich für Bielefeld entscheiden? In Bielefeld sind relativ viele größere aber auch mittelständische Firmen.
Die natürlich auch gucken, was sind Attraktionsfaktoren in einer Stadt. Und da gab es eine Befragung, die zum Bielefelder Stadtgrün durchgeführt wurden. Eine repräsentative Bevölkerungsbefragung und ich war mit dieser Befragung, mit den Ergebnissen und einem Kollegen unterwegs. Uli Mai seines Zeichens Soziologe und wir haben die Ergebnisse der Befragung vorgestellt. Und was für uns sehr interessant war, je nachdem mit welchen Interessengruppen wir zu tun haben, haben wir eine sehr unterschiedliche Wertschätzung dieses Themas als solches erfahren. Das ist natürlich ein Heimspiel bei Naturschützern, das ist gar keine Frage. Das Ganze wird aber schon auch schwieriger, wenn es um das Thema geht, Ausweisung von Gewerbegebieten und Stadtgrün. Das Thema wird nochmal schwieriger, das habe ich jetzt auch in den letzten Jahren immer gesehen, unabhängig jetzt von diesem Bielfeld 2000plus Projekt, was ich erzählt habe.
Wenn es darum geht, Grünräume und eventuelle Arbeitsplätze, da kommen Sie ganz schnell in eine Diskussion, die sehr konkret, die wenig abstrakt ist und wo es um Bewertung und Bewertungsmaßstäbe geht. Und ich glaube, da müssen wir noch mehr tun, dieses Thema der Bedeutung von innerstädtischen Grün- und Blauräumen in verschiedene Bevölkerungsschichten und auch in verschiedene Interessengruppierungen hinein zu tragen. Weil ich glaube, das ist nicht für viele Leute einfach einzusehen, dass wir eine ganze Reihe von sogenannten Gesundheitsdeterminanten, also Faktoren, haben, die Gesundheit und Wohlbefinden in einer Wohngegend bestimmen. Und da wäre mir dann gelegen, dass wir diese sogenannten Gesundheitsdeterminanten, die ja eben auch Lebensqualität und Wohlbefinden und damit auch Attraktivität eines Standortes als Arbeitsplatz mitbestimmen, in Blick nehmen.
Gehen wir mal weg von Grün und Blau, was ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch die naheliegenden Aspekte von einem gesunden Dasein in der Stadt ist, aber es gibt ja auch noch andere Aspekte. Was natürlich alle extrem prägt ist der Verkehr. Und damit im Zusammenhang Lärmbelastung. War das auch Teil Ihres Forschungsblicks?
Also in dem Kontext war es ausdrücklich kein Teil des Forschungskontextes, weil es ging hier in diesem Zusammenhang wirklich darum, wie ich eingangs sagte, die gesundheitsförderlichen Aspekte anzugucken. Also wir unterscheiden ja auf der einen Seite sogenannte salutogenen Faktoren. Also Faktoren, die die Gesundheit erhalten. Und wir unterscheiden auf der anderen Seite die pathogenetischen, also die krankmachenden Faktoren. Und was wir uns im Rahmen jetzt dieses Projektes vom Stifterverband angeschaut haben, sind rein diese salutogenen, also gesundheitsförderlichen Faktoren. Ich hatte ja eingangs gesagt, das Förderprogramm sollte die beiden Leitkonzepte, nachhaltige Gesundheitsförderung und nachhaltige Entwicklung, am Beispiel urbaner Räume miteinander verknüpfen und da ist eben das Thema ganz klar gewesen.
Wir gucken uns die gesundheitsförderlichen Potenziale an dieser Stelle genauer an. Um eben zu wissen, wie kann eigentlich einerseits natürliche Umwelt, aber auch die bebaute Umwelt in Interaktion stehen. Also klassisch jetzt diesen Gesundheitsdeterminanten entsprechend haben wir da geguckt, welche Rückkopplung gibt es zwischen beispielsweise eben natürlicher Umwelt und der menschlichen Gesundheit bzw. dem menschlichen Wohlbefinden. Wir haben ausdrücklich eben in dem Zusammenhang nicht auf Lärm oder Luftschadstoffe geschaut.
Aber trotzdem ist das natürlich ein Thema oder, mit dem Sie sich sicherlich mal beschädigt haben?
Also das ist für mich die andere Seite der Medaille, hatte ich eingangs gesagt. Ich glaube wir müssen beides tun. Wir müssen natürlich Schadfaktoren, de auf den Menschen wirken, reduzieren. Dazu gehören mikrobiologische Faktoren, also Bakterien, Schimmelpilze beispielsweise, die in Innenräumen immer noch eine Rolle spielen. Wir müssen aber eben auch die klassischen Schadfaktoren im Bereich Boden, Wasser, Luft der natürlichen Umwelt in den Blick nehmen. Da ist eine Verpflichtung da. Und da haben wir auch genügend Daten, das sage ich ausdrücklich gerade, Sie haben die Luftschadstoffe angesprochen. Wenn Sie sich die Feinstaubsituation innerstädtisch anschauen, wenn Sie sich die Stickoxidsituation innerstädtisch anschauen, dann haben wir da klare Belege, dass nicht nur Lebensqualität verschlechtert wird von Menschen, sondern dass wir erhöhte Krankheitslasten, so nennen wir das ja, haben.
Also es heißt es geht den Menschen schlechter und sie versterben früher. Also wir haben eine vorgezogene Sterblichkeit. Und da gilt es was dran zu tun. Das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Was denn?
Ich bin vielleicht nochmal kurz an diesem Punkt sehr eng verbunden und das ist natürlich auch der Tatsache geschuldet, dass ich längere Zeit auch mal in Krankenhäusern unterwegs gewesen bin in verschiedenen Rollen. Wir haben bestimmte empfindliche Personengruppen. Also wenn Sie beispielsweise jemanden nehmen mit einem Asthma bronchiale oder mit einer chronischen Bronchitis beispielsweise, dann sind das genau die Personengruppen, die besonders betroffen sind. Und das heißt wir müssen natürlich regulieren und da haben wir ja in Deutschland auch eine sehr sehr lange Tradition im Bereich der Luftschadstoffe. Also Thema Feinstaubregulation oder Stickoxide beispielsweise, die in denBlick genommen werden, um da entsprechend dann auch Gesundheitsgewinne, auch das ist mir an der Stelle nochmal wichtig, wir reden von Krankheitslasten, aber eben auch Gesundheitsgewinne, erzielen zu können.
Das heißt für den einzelnen, der beispielsweise ein Asthma hat oder beispielsweise eine chronische Bronchitis hat, dass ich die individuelle Krankheitslast reduziere. Das heißt er oder sie hat schlichtweg weniger Symptome. Das heißt aber auch fürs Gesundheitssystem, das deutlich weniger Kosten beispielsweise anfallen. Also auch das hat eine gesundheitsökonomische Fragestellung immanent, mit dem wir uns auseinandersetzen müssen. Und da ist ja auf EU-Ebene viel unterwegs. Also Stichwort Feinstaubreduktion. Die Stickoxidreduktion ist das nächste was ansteht. Also Diskussionen beispielsweise eben um blaue Plakette. Ich glaube das sind genau die richtigen Diskussionen, wo wir gucken müssen, sind unsre Mobilitätsstrukturen eigentlich noch die die nachhaltig sind.
Blaue Plakette bezieht sich auf eine erweiterte Umweltzone, die in der Diskussion des Ausschluss von Dieselfahrzeugen im Innenstadtbereich, richtig?
Genau. Es gibt ja diverse Ideen schon seit langem, wie ich regulieren kann. Also die Regulation ist ja eigentlich die politische Möglichkeit, die durchaus greifen kann in diesem Zusammenhang. Und ich glaube, da gilt es schnell und auch sehr klug innovative Mobilitätskonzepte noch einmal auf den Weg zu bringen.
Interessanter Punkt. Ich meine ich höre auch bei Ihnen viel raus, dass Sie neben der Forschung immer den Blick haben auf wie lässt sich das durchsetzen. Wie lässt sich das politisch vermitteln. Dass sozusagen die wissenschaftliche Arbeit hier auch schon noch einen zweiten Schritt mitmacht, neben der eigentlichen Forschung, und auch immer wieder überlegt … Also Erkenntnis allein super, hilft aber erst mal nichts, wenn sich nicht was ändert. Ich höre bei Ihnen immer raus, immer gleich die Überlegung mit, wo geht man hin, mit wem spricht man auf welche Art und Weise, wie überzeugt man Kommunen, wie überzeugt man höhergestellte politische Entscheidungsebenen, um hier in einen Dialog einzutreten.
Also die Idee ist schon zu wissen, wofür man etwas tut. Wo ich gerade ein bisschen stutze ist, ob es wirklich so zu formulieren ist, wie überzeugt man. Weil ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, wenn man die richtigen Menschen findet, dann braucht man nicht mehr zu überzeugen. Ich glaube wichtig ist, die richtigen Menschen mit den richtigen Ideen zu finden. Und ich glaube es sind sehr viele Personen gerade im politischen Raum derzeit unterwegs, die selber sehr kluge Ideen haben und wo wir als Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler recht offene Türen finden, um Ideen auch mitzugeben. Oder gemeinschaftlich auf Machbarkeit zu prüfen. Weil das ist ja immer ein interessantes Spannungsfeld, was mir auch sehr bewusst ist. Ich habe da eine Luxusposition eigentlich an einer deutschen Hochschule, die finde ich sehr forschungsfördernd ist von der Grundhaltung.
Das ist an der Universität Bielefeld so. Das ist ein hohes Maß an Freiheit. Und man kann sich die Themen in vielen Bereichen auch sehr breit suchen. Das ist im politischen Raum ja so, dass naturgemäß über die Legislaturperiode zunächst erst mal eine zeitliche Eingrenzung erfolgt. Und das heißt es muss ja eine Priorisierung auch da sein. Und ich glaube, dass in verschiedensten Ministerien beispielsweise auch sehr viele engagierte Akteure unterwegs sind, die auch mittel- und langfristige Perspektiven schon entwickelt haben und es gilt, da Allianzen zu finden. Mit wem arbeitet man zusammen? Das gilt im Übrigen auf kommunaler Ebene auch. Das haben wir beispielsweise in der Stadt Gelsenkirchen, die ja eine unserer Modellstädte im Rahmen jetzt des Förderprogramms der Fritz und Hildegard Berg Stiftung waren, bewusst auch so gemacht.
Wir haben die Stadt Gelsenkirchen ausgesucht, einmal aus dem Grund, wir wollten nicht wieder die großen Städte beforschen, die werden sowieso viel mehr beforscht. Also wenn Sie Hamburg nehmen, wenn Sie Berlin oder Stuttgart nehmen. Ein wichtiger Grund ist, dass wir sowohl in Bielefeld als auch in Gelsenkirchen wussten, wir haben da sehr engagierte kommunale Akteure und darum geht es mir in meiner Arbeit. Also sowohl auf der kommunalen als auch auf der Landes-  und wenn es eben geht noch auf der Bundesebene die Leute zu finden, mit denen man Allianzen finden kann in Hinblick auf Entwicklung einer gesünderen Umwelt.
Aber wenn wir jetzt mal das Beispiel der blauen Plakette nehmen, wo ja im Prinzip, nicht nur, aber vor allem auch, eine Reduzierung der Aktivität von Dieselmotoren quasi groß auf den Fahnen steht. In Deutschland, wo wir jetzt gerade durch Dieselgate den zumindest von VW ausgehenden Skandal festgestellt haben, dass selbst ja die bisher gegebenen Zusagen nicht zutreffen. Dass die Geräte sich abschalten, wenn es kalt wird und teilweise glaube ich das 15fache an Stickoxiden auswerfen als irgendwo mal auf irgendeinem Zettel steht und auch vor allem in irgendwelchen Prüfnormen. Ist der politische Widerstand in dem Bereich nicht trotzdem extrem hoch? Weil ja immer gleich gegengesetzt wird mit, das schadet ja der Wirtschaft?
Ja gut, ich meine steter Tropfen höhlt den Stein. Da habe ich eine ganz klare Haltung. Mich verpflichtet das was mich und ich finde das ist das worum Wissenschaft auch ringen muss, mich verpflichtet schon die Erkenntnis in diesem Fall zur gesundheitsschädigenden Wirkung. Das ist mein erstes Primat. Und die Kunst wird ja sein zu begreifen, dass wir gerade die ökonomische Argumentationslinie auflösen müssen dahingehend, dass wir unter Umständen auch viel viel mehr Sekundär- oder Tertiärkosten, die entstehen, in den Blick nehmen müssen. Und das wird ja derzeit nicht getan.
Also dass man nicht nur sagt, klar da gibt es Arbeitsplätze etc., aber die Gesundheitskosten, die Nachfolgekosten, Versorgungskosten etc., die damit verbunden sind, übersteigen das unter Umständen oder schränken zumindest den potenziellen Gewinn an der Stelle stark ein.
Also eine klassische Idee des immer wieder ressortübergreifenden Vorgehens. Mit welchem Recht ist das Primat der Wirtschaft das einzige was zählt? Also es gibt beispielsweise, Sie hatten mich ja vorhin nach konkreten Vorschlägen gefragt, es gibt beispielsweise in Australien, die Stadt Sydney, aber auch andere Städte haben das auf kommunaler Ebene gemacht, die haben eine sogenannten healthy urban development Checklist entwickelt und haben als Maßgabe, dass jede Veränderung in einer Stadt abgeprüft werden muss auf gesundheitliche Bedeutung. Wenn man sich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lässt.
Jede Maßnahme?
Jede Maßnahme. Da muss jetzt nichts bei rauskommen, aber die haben zumindest mal einen Stock einen Meter über die Erde gehalten und haben gesagt, ihr springt jetzt mal darüber und guckt, hat eure Maßnahme gesundheitlichen Bezug. Und das finde ich eigentlich ganz klug. Man kann durch eine Checkliste relativ schnell durchgehen und kann sagen, das hat keine gesundheitliche Relevanz. Man kann aber auch an einigen Stellen stoppen müssen und muss sich dazu verhalten. Und das ist für mich etwas Prävention oder Vorsorge im ganz ganz klassischen Sinne. Dass ich also im Vorfeld von Maßnahmen etwas zur gesundheitlichen Relevanz sagen muss. Und so etwas könnte man sich natürlich in anderen Bereichen genauso vorstellen. Also wenn es um das Thema Mobilität geht, wenn es um das Thema Energiewende beispielsweise geht. So was könnte ich mir auch vorstellen. Thema Stärkung von Biodiversität in Städten.
Es ist nämlich gar nicht so einfach, wie wir beide es jetzt vorhin immer besprechen haben. Ich kann unter Umständen nämlich auch ganz klar sagen, ich müsste auch nochmal gucken, wenn ich Grünräume in Städten verbessern und verändern will, dann muss ich aber solche Pflanzen nehmen, die ein geringes allergenes Potenzial haben. Weil wir eine hohe Anzahl von Allergikern in den Städten haben. Also Sie sehen, das ganze System ist relativ kompliziert. Aber ich möchte immer dafür werben, dass das Thema Gesundheit eigentlich ein Thema ist, was in allen Bereichen eine Relevanz hat. Und das ist ja etwas was anknüpft an eine alte Strategie der Weltgesundheitsorganisation, die da heißt health in all policies. Also dass ich übergreifend betrachten muss, sind eben gesundheitliche Belange durch verschiedene Aktivitäten dann auch betroffen? Und solange wir es dabei belassen, Gesundheit als ein Gut unter vielen zu sehen und es immer zur Seite zu schieben, dann glaube ich kommen wir in vielen aktuellen Schritten nicht sehr viel weiter.
Was gesamtgesellschaftliche Fragestellungen und auch Lösungsansätze angeht. Also gerade vor dem Hintergrund Nachhaltigkeit, beispielsweise was Sie gerade auch angesprochen hatten.
Was ist denn so Ihr Gefühl, wie gut ziehen denn die Kommunen in diesem Bereich mit? Weil ich meine, wenn jetzt Gruppen kommen, die forschen, ja lassen wir mal die komplette Stadtentwicklung noch etwas komplizierter werden, hier haben wir noch 50 neue Bedingungen, auf die jedes Projekt hin abgeklopft werden muss. Und ich meine Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen etc. gibt es ja bei Baumaßen etc., Planung von Wohngebieten ohnehin ja schon. Wie ist denn dann die Reaktion?
Naja es gibt da Kommunen, die sind da sehr offen. Also ich meine Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung kann man sich ja auch nochmal drüber unterhalten, wie die denn de facto ausgeführt werden. Da steht ja oft Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung drauf. Da ist Gesundheit so gut wie nicht drin. Da wird ein bisschen Lärm geprüft und gut ist. Es gibt eine andere Figur, die international sehr viel stärker gespielt wird, das ist das sogenannte Health Impact Assessment, also wo man viel breiter guckt. Und ich verstehe so ein bisschen Ihre Besorgnis, dass Sie sagen, das ist zu breit für die Kommunen. Ich mache aber die Erfahrung, dass die Kommunen sehr wohl bereit sind, darauf einzugehen, weil sie genau wissen, welchen Stellenwert Lebensqualität und Gesundheit für die Bevölkerung haben. Das ist auf der einen Seite weil sie eine hohe vielfach intrinsische Motivation haben zum Thema Gesundheitsschutz, die Erfahrung mache ich. Und im Übrigen was heißt Komplexität?
Wir tun ja eigentlich nichts anderes. Ich vergleiche das mal mit einem Besuch im Blumengeschäft. Sie gehen ja auch in den Blumenladen und gucken sich die einzelnen Blumen an und entscheiden sich dann, welchen Blumenstrauß Sie binden. Und Sie entscheiden nach Kriterien. Sie entscheiden nach Alter, nach den Charaktereigenschaften, nach der Person, die den Blumenstrauß kriegen soll und ich glaube das wird die Kunst sein, das erst mal aufzufächern und dann aber so zu bündeln und auch tragbar und handhabbar für die Kommunen zu machen. Und die Erfahrung mache ich, die sind auf einem sehr sehr guten Weg, das sehe ich eigentlich immer wieder. Und die sind auch gewillt, das zu tun. Also weil das Thema Lebensqualität und Gesundheit ein Thema ist, was sehr hohe Bedeutungen für die Mitarbeitenden dort hat, was aber auch eine hohe Bedeutung für die Lebenssituation hier der Bevölkerung hat. Als das Thema Bildungsangebote oder auch soziale Benachteiligung, Teilhabechancen, das ist ja etwas, was die Kommunen vor Ort spüren, die Leute haben ja einen Bedarf.
Und die haben auch einen Bedarf, in Prozesse eingebunden zu werden. Also das Beispiel jetzt hier der partizipativen Prozesse, auch da sind viele Kommunen finde ich sehr gut auf dem Weg und offen. Und unserer Verpflichtung glaube ich ist, aus dem wissenschaftlichen Bereich nochmal zu zeigen, dass beispielsweise ein Health Impact Assessment so kompliziert dann auch nicht ist oder dass man es eben auch durchaus machen kann. Und es gibt ja international viele Städte, die da gut unterwegs sind.
Ich unterstelle jetzt mal, dass das Interesse und die Bereitschaft da mitzuspielen nicht bei allen Kommunen gleich ist, sondern dass es da solche und solche gibt.
Auf jeden Fall.
Lässt sich da irgendwie ablesen, ist das eine Frage der Größe der Kommunen, ist das eine Frage der Regionalist, haben wir hier irgendein Ost-West, Nord-Süd Gefälle, ist das eine Frage von Verdichtung und wie urban diese Räume jetzt tatsächlich sind? Oder habe Sie den Eindruck, dass das eigentlich unabhängig davon ist, wo es positiv aufgenommen wird und wo nicht?
Ich glaube, dass das sehr weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt wäre, wenn ich dazu was sagen könnte, weil ich bin natürlich immer nur exemplarisch in bestimmten Kommunen unterwegs. Und ein Punkt, den ich sicherlich festmachen kann, das Engagement der Einzelakteure in den Kommunen bestimmt das was passiert. Das ist der eine Punkt. Also wirklich die intrinsische Motivation, die Leute haben, die in den Kommunen oder auch in den Landesbehörden arbeiten. Der andere Punkt ist natürlich auch ein von außen gesetzter Druck auf die Kommune. Also wenn Kommunen feststellen, dass Bevölkerung in stärkerem Maße wegzieht, macht sie sich eher Gedanken. Das muss man auch sagen. Was an Stellgrößen verändert werden muss.
Also wie schrumpfende Städte, als gesellschaftliches Phänomen im Osten...
Warum schrumpft eine Stadt? Nochmal genau zu gucken, ist das wirklich das Thema Arbeitsplatz alleine. Ist das nicht das Wohnumfeld beispielsweise, was ja vielfach miteinander in Beziehung ist. Ob das von der Größe abhängt kann ich nicht sagen, aber ich bin da auch in zu wenigen Kommunen vergleichend unterwegs. Das müsste man wirklich empirisch mal machen. Ich kann das exemplarisch dann immer festmachen, aber da jetzt ich sage mal bundesweit einen Aussage, da tu ich mich schwer.
Welche, wenn wir jetzt mal so ein bisschen den Blick auf die jungen Wissenschaftler richten, wen sollte denn dieses Thema noch interessieren, die vielleicht bisher noch nicht den Blick drauf geworfen haben? Ich meine wir haben über die Interdisziplinarität des Themas ja eingangs schon gesprochen. Dass es vor allem medizinisch biologisch aufgehängtes Thema ist, aber wie wir jetzt im Gespräch ja auch gemerkt haben, beileibe nicht nur. Wie könnte diese Interdisziplinarität an der Stelle denn noch erweitert werden? Was gibt es denn noch für andere Fächer, die hier vielleicht ein Potenzial haben, zu dieser Debatte beizutragen?
Also wir haben ja relativ lange Erfahrung zusammen mit der TU Dortmund beispielsweise mit den Stadt- und Raumplanern, Lehrveranstaltungen zusammen zu machen. Also wir haben hier mit der Kollegin Sabine Baumgart von der TU Dortmund und Frau Dr. Andrea Rüdiger eine lange Erfahrung was interdisziplinäre Exkursionen angeht. Das heißt das kann man sich so vorstellen, dass Studierende jetzt der Stadt- und Raumplanung zusammen mit Studierenden der Gesundheitswissenschaften zusammen unterwegs sind und bestimmte Themen bearbeiten. Der Hintergrund ist der, dass wir eben genau aus den unterschiedlichen Perspektiven auf eine und die gleiche Sache schauen und eine Problemlösung versuchen. Also für mich sind die Stadt- und Raumplaner natürlich genau die Menschen, die wir da mit ins Feld holen müssen.
Das sind Architekten, gar keine Frage, weil die Architekten natürlich auch die bebauten Räume, die bebauten Wohnräume schaffen und das sind für mich an der Stelle natürlich auch ganz ganz wichtig, hatte ich vorhin schon genannt, die Bereiche Toxikologie, die es unbedingt aufzuwerten gilt. Das ist der Bereich des ganz ganz klassischen Biologen, des Naturschutzes auch beispielsweise, auch etwas was zunehmend eigentlich an Ausbildungsstandorten rückläufig ist und das ist natürlich auch der Bereich der medizinischen Geografie beispielsweise. Es ist sehr vielfältig. Die Landschaftsarchitekten. Das wäre etwas, wenn ich mir etwas wünschen dürfte, eine große Forschergruppe mit sehr sehr unterschiedlichen Fachdisziplinen. Also so bin ich ja damals, als ich nach Bielefeld berufen wurde, eine neue Arbeitsgruppe zu gründen zum Themenfeld Umwelt und Gesundheit, das war immer meine Idealvorstellung, unterschiedliche Fachkulturen in eine Arbeitsgruppe zu bringen.
Und das ist auf der einen Seite hochspannend, es ist auf der anderen Seite aber auch nicht ganz einfach, weil einfach die berufsbiografische Sozialisation sehr unterschiedlich ist. Die Sprache ist sehr unterschiedlich. Sie reden manchmal über dasselbe oder meinen über dasselbe zu reden und es ist eigentlich ganz anders. Und manchmal denken Sie sie liegen weit auseinander und dann ist es ganz eng zusammen. Aber ich glaube das ist etwas, wo man im Bereich Forschung noch Schritte weitergehen könnte und natürlich immer in Zusammenarbeit mit kommunalen konkreten Fragestellungen. Also mein Idealbild ist wirklich schon, dass die Leute vor Ort sagen mir, das und das sind Themenbereiche, die ich mich umtreiben und ich sage, finde ich spannend oder ich sage, finde ich nicht spannend und ich kann dann sozusagen meine Perspektive da zuspielen. Und gemeinschaftlich bearbeiten wir dann das Themenfeld und entwickeln eine neue Methode. Und mit der Bevölkerung zusammen, auch das ist mir nochmal wichtig.
Nicht über die Bevölkerung, sondern im wirklich klassischen Sinne einer partizipativen Herangehensweise mit den Bevölkerungsgruppen, an die wir bislang oft schlecht rankommen.
Erinnert mich jetzt auch ein bisschen an das Gespräch, das hier Forschergeist 24 mit Klaus Kümmerer hatte, der sich ja insbesondere mit der Frage nachhaltiger Chemie und speziell eben auch der Frage des Wassers in unserer Zivilisation beschäftigt hat. Auch stand die interdisziplinäre Forschung im Mittelpunkt und vielleicht so zum Abschluss, was sind denn die Grenzen dieses interdisziplinären und auch des transdisziplinären Ansatzes? Ich meine das klingt jetzt schön so, ja wir müssen das noch erweitern. Wenn ich mir dann irgendwann vorstelle, man sitzt da in so einer Forschergruppe mit 50 verschiedenen Disziplinen und hast noch mit 80 Kommunen zu tun.
So viele müssen es ja nicht sein.
Genau da ist dann wahrscheinlich irgendwo so die Grenze. Was würden Sie denn sozusagen als ein gesundes Optimum empfinden, wie weit dürfen diese Disziplinen auseinander sein, ist das kein Kriterium? Oder ist die Größe wirklich irgendwann ein Problem, weil es sich einfach auch nicht mehr managen lässt? Oder ist da einfach viel Luft nach oben?
Also die Größe ist sicherlich ein Problem, weil sie dann nicht mehr miteinander sprechen und auch nicht miteinander wirklich im klassischen Sinne vernetzt sind. Ich glaube es ist eher eine Limitierung der Haltung, also wenn sie nicht bereit sind, miteinander in Kommunikation zu treten und Positionen zu verlassen, dann ist das eine Limitierung. Und die andere Limitierung ist, zu früh zu sagen, das ist mir zu komplex. Das ist die andere Seite. Solange aber die beteiligten Akteure auch in Krisenzeiten bereit sind, miteinander zu sprechen und solche Themen weiter zu spielen. Und das ist ja schon, wenn Sie Forschergruppen haben, die laufen ja manchmal 3-5-7 Exzellenzinitiative noch länger, da brauchen Sie ein Standing, miteinander zu reden und auch Frustrationsphasen zu überleben. Und das ist glaube ich der hohe Anspruch.
Wenn dann jeder im Rahmen einer solchen Forschergruppe unterwegs ist und dann sozusagen sein Thema gefunden hat, dass er oder sie dann nicht einfach mit einer Einbahnstraße weiterläuft und sagt, so das ist jetzt wichtig
und ich muss mit meinem Programm durchkommen, sondern die Kunst ist, in den verschiedenen Situationen auch immer die Zeit zu finden, miteinander zu reden. Und auch vielleicht nochmal einen Richtungswechsel einzugehen. Und Mut zu haben vielleicht, auch wenn ein Projekt nur drei Jahre dauert, nicht sofort loszulegen, sondern sich eine gesunde Zeit zu nehmen und drüber nachzudenken, wie konzipieren sie ein Projekt. Also ich selber durfte mal, ganz anderes Thema, die erste repräsentative Untersuchung mit durchführen als sozusagen Halbleiterin zur Beschreibung der Lebenssituation von Menschen mit Behinderungen in Deutschland. Und da war es so, da bin ich schon fast nervös geworden. Wir hatten drei Jahre Laufzeit und wir haben ein halbes Jahr geredet und überlegt, wie machen wir das? Und im Nachgang finde ich sind das genau die wichtigen Zeiten.
Sich einfach auch die Zeit für eine Orientierung zu nehmen, weil ansonsten …
Und denken.
… sonst stellt man ja vielleicht später fest, oh wären wir mal am Anfang nicht gleich irgendwo abgebogen, jetzt führt uns das hier in die Bredouille.
Nachdenken, miteinander reden und mit den Menschen reden, über die man arbeitet oder für die man arbeitet. Das Thema über jemand zu arbeiten sollte man eigentlich verlassen, sondern die Idee muss immer sein, mit jemandem zu arbeiten und mit den Leuten zu reden.
Ja ein schönes Schlusswort würde ich sagen Frau Hornberg. Vielen Dank.
Ich danke auch.
Für die Ausführungen hier zu Stadt und Gesundheit. Und ich muss sagen, letzten Endes auch genauso im Mittelpunkt stand hier die Fragestellung eigentlich auch der interdisziplinären und der transdisziplinären Arbeit, die in diesem Themenfeld, aber nicht nur dort, eng miteinander verbunden ist. Gut vielen Dank natürlich auch wieder an alle Zuhörer da draußen, es geht weiter mit Forschergeist in wenigen Wochen und bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis bald.